the observable universe is a big place
that's been around for more than 13
billion years
up to two trillion galaxies made up of
something like 20
000 billion billion stars surround our
home galaxy
in the milky way alone scientists assume
there are some 40 billion
earth-like planets in the habitable zone
of their stars
when we look at these numbers it's hard
to imagine that there is nobody else out
there
it would change our perception of
ourselves forever
if we found others just knowing that
this vast place is not dead
would shift our perspective outward and
could help us get over our irrelevant
quarrels
but before looking for our new best
friends or worst enemies
we have a problem to solve what are we
actually looking for
in a universe that big and old we have
to assume that civilizations
start millions of years apart from each
other and develop in different
directions and speeds
so not only are we looking over
distances of dozens to hundreds of
thousands of light years
we're looking for a civilization ranging
from caveman
to super advanced so we need a
conceptual framework to enable us to
think better thoughts
that make us able to search better are
there universal rules that intelligent
species follow
currently our civilization sample size
is only one
so we may make incorrect assumptions
based solely on ourselves
still better than nothing we know that
humans started out with nothing but
minds and hands that could build tools
we know that humans are curious
competitive greedy for resources
and expansionist the more of these
qualities our ancestors had
the more successful they were in the
civilization building game
being one with nature is nice but it's
not the path to irrigation systems or
gunpowder
or cities so it's reasonable to assume
that aliens able to take over their home
planet also have these qualities
and if aliens have to follow the same
laws of physics
then there is a measurable metric for
progress
energy use human progress can be
measured very precisely
by how much energy we extracted from our
environment and how we made it usable to
do things
we started with muscles until we learned
to control
fire then we made machines that used
kinetic energy
from water and wind as our machines got
better and our knowledge of materials
expanded
we began to harness the concentrated
energy from dead plants we dug up from
the ground
as our energy consumption grew
exponentially so did the abilities of
our civilization
between 1800 and 2015 population size
had increased
sevenfold while humanity was consuming
25 times more energy
it's likely that this process will
continue into the far
future based on these facts scientist
nikolai kardashev developed a method of
categorizing civilizations
from cave dwellers to gods ruling over
galaxies
the kardashev scale a method of ranking
civilizations by their energy use
the scale has been refined and expanded
on over the decades but in general it
puts civilizations
into four different categories a type 1
civilization
is able to use the available energy of
their home planet
a type 2 civilization is able to use the
available energy of their star and
planetary system
a type 3 civilization is able to use the
available energy of their galaxy
a type 4 civilization is able to use the
available energy of multiple galaxies
these levels differ by orders of
magnitude
it's like comparing an ant colony to a
human metropolitan area
to ants we are so complex and powerful
we might as well be gods
so to make the scale more useful we need
subcategories
on the lower end of the spectrum there
are type 0 to type 1 civilizations
anything from hunter-gatherers to
something we could achieve in the next
few hundred years
these might actually be abundant in the
milky way
but a civilization that is not actively
transmitting radio signals into space
might be as close as our nearest stellar
neighbor the alpha centauri system
and we would have no way of realizing
they exist
but even if they transmitted radio
signals like we do
it might not be very helpful on an
interstellar scale
humanity is practically invisible
our signals may extend over an
impressive 200 light years
but this is only a tiny fraction of the
milky way
and even if someone were listening after
a few light years
our signals decay into noise impossible
to identify as the source of an
intelligent species
today humanity ranks at about level 0.75
we have altered our planet we've created
huge structures
mined and stripped mountains removed
rainforests and drain swamps
we've created rivers and lakes and
changed the composition
and temperature of the atmosphere if
progress
continues and we don't make earth
uninhabitable
we will become a full type one
civilization in the next few hundred
years
any civilization that becomes a type one
is bound to look outside
because it's likely that it's still
curious competitive greedy
and expansionist the next reasonable
step towards transitioning to type 2
is trying to alter and mine other
planets and bodies
this might start with outposts in space
transition to infrastructure
and industries near the home planet move
on to colonies and end with terraforming
other planets by changing their
atmosphere
their rotation or position as a
civilization expands and uses more and
more stuff and space
its energy consumption scales with them
so at some point
they may embark on the largest project a
lower type 2 civilization can take on
harnessing the energy of their star by
building a dyson swarm
once this megastructure is finished
energy has become practically
unlimited for molding the home system
however they see fit
if they are still curious competitive
greedy and expansionist
and now have complete control over their
home system
stellar infrastructure in place and the
energy output of a star
the next frontier moves to other stars
light years away
for a type 2 civilization the distance
to other stars might feel like the
distance between earth and pluto does to
us today
technically within reach but only with
immense investments in terms of time
ingenuity and resources this begins
their transition towards type three
this step is so far beyond us that it
becomes hard to imagine what exactly
these challenges will look like
and how they'll be solved will they be
able to find a solution to the vast
distances and travel times of hundreds
or thousands of years
will they be able to communicate and
keep a shared culture and biology
between colonies
light years apart or will they split
into separate type 2 civilizations
maybe even different species are there
deadly challenges between the stars
so the closer a species gets to type 3
the harder it becomes to fathom what it
might actually look like
they might discover new physics may
understand and control
dark matter and energy or be able to
travel faster than light
we might be unable to grasp their
motives technology
and actions humans are the ants
trying to understand the galactic
metropolitan area
a high type 2 civilization might already
consider humanity too primitive to even
talk to
a type 3 civilization might feel about
us like we feel about the bacteria
living on the anthill
maybe they wouldn't even consider us
conscious or our survival relevant
we could only pray that they're nice
gods
[Music]
but the scale doesn't necessarily end
here some scientists suggest there might
be type 4 and type 5 civilizations
whose influence stretches over galaxy
clusters or superclusters
structures comprising thousands of
galaxies and trillions of stars
ultimately there might be a type omega
civilization
able to manipulate the entire universe
and possibly others
type omega civilizations might be the
actual
creators of our universe for reasons
beyond our comprehension
maybe they were just bored as flawed as
this classification may be
this thought experiment is already
telling us interesting things
if our ideas about the nature of species
that form interstellar civilizations
is sort of correct then we can be pretty
sure that there are no civilizations of
type 3
and beyond near the milky way their
influence would in all likelihood be so
all-encompassing
and their technology so far above our
own that we couldn't miss them
the galaxy should flash with their
activity in thousands of star systems
we should be able to see or detect their
artifacts or movements between different
parts of their empire even if a type 3
civilization did exist in the past
and died a mysterious death we should be
able to detect
some of the remnants of their empire but
when scientists looked they didn't find
remnants of harvested stars decaying
megastructures
or scars of great interstellar walls
so they're very likely not out there and
never were
in a sense this is very sad but also
very reassuring
it leaves the galaxy to us and others
similar to us
so the most promising civilizations to
look for may be somewhere in the
spectrum from type 1.5
to type 2.5 they wouldn't be too
advanced to
understand them and their motives they
may have finished their first
megastructures
and they might be in the process of
moving staff between stars
and transmitting enormous amounts of
information into space
by accident or on purpose they would
probably also
look to the stars and look for others
then again
maybe we've got it all wrong maybe
progress to type 2
does not mean expanding outwards and
humanity
is still too immature to imagine
otherwise
for now all we really know is that we
haven't seen anybody yet
but we've only just started looking
until we finally find friendly super
aliens and can ask them to explain the
rules of the universe to us
most of us have to make do with learning
stuff ourselves
whether you're going back to school
leaving home for the first time or if
you're just entering a new phase in your
life
our shop is stocked and ready for all
your back-to-school needs
notebooks and notepads to organize your
work stickers and mugs to make things
look nice
lots and lots of posters to turn your
dorm or room into an inspiring oasis of
knowledge
we have new shirts and for the first
time eight chords quartz gazant earth
sweater
all of these products are designed and
produced with love
by the kudzkesant merch burbs how much
is the easiest way to support what we do
and keep our videos free for everyone
thank you for watching
[Music]